papa raconte une histoire
il était une fois un roi qui vivait tout
ça au monde il thaï ha en bour pantin de
points mais ce petit nez semble bien
trop long vous connaissez sa silhouette
m'appelle pinocchio voilà des valeurs de
l'école unique
vous connaissez ces mensonges ajouter
librement malade tu vois ce qui arrive à
ceux qui dise des mensonges tu me fais
de la peine
et pourquoi parce que tu n'es qu'une
tête de bois paresseuse et indiscipliné
al-abyad mangement vespa découverte du
monde découvrez pinocchio comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu plus vraie plus
étonnant que jamais est ce que toi aussi
tu pars au pays des jouets mois aux deux
pieds jambes a mordu à l'hameçon et
diaboliquement
c'est quoi ce cirque 12 août
et j'ai mis dans un sacré pétrin et à
l'heure qu'il est mon père est sûrement
mort de cristallisation clos tu as des
oreilles donne peut-être que si tu te
comportait un peu comme il faut tu
pourrais devenir un vrai petit garçon
c'est vrai 4
où on était
bah oui puis par une nuit de tempête le
maire pris la mer à la recherche de son
fils pinocchio une histoire et perd même
bouleversante magie